well you may not have heard her name
before but until a few days ago Madeline
West her house was the personal
assistant to President Trump
well account she worked hard and did
well at her job it's hard to find anyone
in Washington who doesn't like her and
yet now she's unemployed and humiliated
how'd that happen
well she made the mistake of eating
dinner with a Washington Post reporter
called Phil Rucker at the meal West
Ralph made a couple of catty remarks
about the president's daughters that's
unwise but it's hardly without precedent
that sort of thing can happen at dinners
where wine is served what's stunning
what is really unusual is what happened
next the meal was explicitly
off-the-record and for journalists that
is a bright line that's the brightest of
all lines information journalists learn
in off-the-record conversations
absolutely cannot be shared it's one of
the few unbreakable rules of the
business everybody in the business knows
that but because Madeleine west rahat
worked for Donald Trump Phil Rucker of
the Washington Post decided to break
that rule casually break it according to
multiple sources Phil Rucker decided to
burn Westar out and shared her remarks
with others Westar out was immediately
fired and as we said humiliated her life
completely derailed Rutger meanwhile
returned to Washington the hero in fact
he was happily yapping away on MSNBC
this afternoon his bosses at the
Washington Post issued a statement
telling the rest of us what a great guy
he is hmm